here we go against mr. Kelly on Khalid
amore f that's a very frequent opponent
minus one over 31 games this business is
a is a close one okay arpu drawing a
blank here don't know what this is age
66 i think im just playin no museum it's
probably not the most testing
continuation but don't know this one too
well
hmm well okay I have no clear plan him
okay maybe I get I got a plan because
his because of his moves okay Remy take
him a knight c 1 t 35 this kind of thing
now we have mutual weaknesses on the on
the queenside he's got be five week I've
got see three week
oh that was a that's a drastic decision
not so much because of the bishop pair
of it because of you four square but ok
just tell you straight stuff in your
interesting ok going to take this got
the f5 square and b5 and some
opportunities fallen light don't want to
trade the night not sure that night text
III is a very likely move to happen it
just felt like something you can pre
move
hmm position I like I think yeah a bit
better but ideas here knight c6 is even
an idea then taking on f6 okay isn't 96
winning a pawn knight c6 going to be 725
you see having enough compensation that
I don't believe it really check yeah
this is I didn't really have on the
Raider at all just fell far too weird
but maybe it works maybe he works with
this Bishop here okay I cannot go g3 f4
Bishop d3 looks totally weird
so I can play that stuff unbelievable
okay yeah unbelievable is this is wrong
I mean it doesn't feel like a miracle
that it works but I should have firm
considered this no he's gained some
tambien and it's probably okay well
before that he definitely had had some
problems yeah not happy with this
and I'd have to that's Kim Ji Won
they're the worst is over fam is quite
active now and and turn has challenges
there maybe with this night to invade 93
trying to play Queen to d4 activate my
queen
a ticket takes with the with the with
the rook unfortunately
I don't think that leads to much just
doing them knight on d4 is keeping
everything keeping everything together
okay let's see he's a very ambitious
player always going for the most yeah
the most testing most aggressive stuff
sometimes it turn get hurt some however
okay so time or needs to take on f2
where that might work
and I cannot figure that out in that
time if it works or not
difficult and 30 seconds to to do
something more than shuffle um it's got
rooked it too
29 f 3 here blundering the porn that's
not good I didn't take it though check
check check check Oh My Luck forfeits
fun time yeah okay I had a bed of prolly
winning weekend game beforehand yeah I
was tough I was always down a long time
and he was kind of yeah doing things I
didn't play that well this is a position
where um white is just better and I got
into trouble what I mean okay I know
what I did wrong I mean something that
definitely was wrong what's this this
move this isn't okay the computer likes
it but I didn't like it Queen B 5 with
an advantage yeah yeah maybe maybe but
yeah I mean their whole as I said yes I
also sell everything is super ambitious
yeah the queen is just doing this it has
to protect this and everything is kind
of hmm yeah but
it still takes some guts to go here and
take that that point as the computer
wants to do now it would have been much
better for a human from a human
perspective to play normal moosian I
Brooks into also and I'm eternally
better with the C file the better night
and so on and no complication so that
would have been much easier to play then
and here I didn't like my position and
now he's he's getting he's getting the
the better game and I had to had to
defend this position all of the time
yeah I expected rook takes me three but
he didn't do that I felt that blacks
should be better here my queen doesn't
have a clear perspective who came and
here yeah this this was of the thing
Queen 85 but I wasn't sure I thought you
might be able to take here I it's a draw
though okay I can help I can hold a draw
here how how to do that like here here
this child yelling Queen f6 I didn't see
that one so black has to take check
check check and this is the draw okay
well that's a line I did not see what I
felt that he can take so this is why I
didn't take 85 and okay here Queen f6
would have been winning yeah because
he's got this move okay yeah it felt it
felt very very shaky disposition geox
III was also winning I don't understand
yet why to be honest because he's
getting this one who
yeah I was pretty much all played here
here the worst is over and things should
be equal ish he could take me three here
okay I had 20 seconds yeah from here it
was a mostly blitzing yeah there's this
should be it should end in a draw but
it's ultimately go to this ending where
have I have winning chances here
probably it is winning actually after
King g4 it's okay six seconds here now
anyway it was a big click fest at the
end okay thanks for watching